pendant les vacances les honore et maël
sont venus récupérer leurs grimoire à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet ils
vont jusqu'à 16h30 pour résoudre les
énigmes
on a pris un thème qui s'appelle sait
pas que sorciers avec l'idée de faire un
mix entre des choses qui peuvent sembler
un peu magique et des choses qu'on va
expliquer de façon un peu scientifique
gratter le ballon avec de la laine pour
revoir en tout mais s'il ya quelque
chose mais là ya quelques minutes le
frère et la soeur maîtrise le sort de
lévitation
ils parviennent à déchiffrer le code qui
se cachait sous les feuilles d'aluminium
après au mont-dore direction sabots tard
pour retrouver les caractéristiques des
équidés magique
les apprentis sorciers ont réussi à
maîtriser le cheval noir il faut
désormais regarder le plan pour se
rendre dans les classes de verre de lait
après les sortilèges et la théorie des
animaux fantastiques place aux potions
un bon sorcier doit savoir reconnaître
une composante barbette j'ai pas trop
une fois la liste des ingrédients
trouvés ils apprennent à maîtriser plume
et encre invisible chesser de coque
avant de se rendre à la dernière épreuve
des chiffres est le secret de l'arbre
est un voeu
reste à se frayer un chemin sont 100
participants ont tenté leur chance ce
jour là c'est une très bonne activité
ludique qui se sont bien amusés ils sont
bien pris au jeu et puis bon ben là
c'est des sorciers ils vont aller voir
les ils vont prendre le temps d'aller
voir les animaux léonore et maël n'ont
plus qu'à se procurer robe de sorcier et
baguette magique pour faire leur
nouvelle rentrée dans le monde des
sorciers